[ __ ] is about to go down oh he's
stretching hold on one second I wanna I
don't want him to pull anything while
he's percolating in it yeah I know it's
real prick bruh why were you planning on
doing something against the wall
percolatin I'm gonna percolate all over
that wall let's get three people up here
you said first so if you come on up
first of all I'm gonna introduce you one
at a time
and we'll just start with you right here
grab this microphone okay and so I'm
gonna ask you a couple questions we're
gonna ask everybody the same questions
so get yourself ready first of all what
is your name Jennifer hi Jennifer
what's your name man Tyler's mom has got
it goin up
[Applause]
I love seeing parents playing spending
time with their [ __ ] kids it's really
nice your name is Jennifer right into
the microphone for Jennifer
Jennifer's get some sparkly nails I like
that [ __ ] all right here we go I'm a
little high I got distracted I apologize
all right Jennifer on a scale of one to
ten one being Elaine from Seinfeld
and ten is being pre pedophile Michael
Jackson Oh too soon sorry where do you
rate yourself as a dancer I'm a
ballerina and a Zumba instructor so I'm
gonna go with like nine you're a
ballerina and a Zumba instructor but did
you did you see yourself get on the
stage I was awful
I was like oh [ __ ] is she gonna be able
to do this Tyler's not laughing now at
all if someone was gonna describe your
style of dancing what would it be one
word athletic sultry sexy sexy Jenn is a
sexy dancer her best moves the hips and
she is a nine [ __ ] are you
hoping your mom's a good dancer or a bad
dancer bad yeah I know that
and Tyler when she said heard the best
name of her best dance is the hips how
did that make you feel in your heart
pretty good good good I just want you to
know it gave like eight dudes in here
partials so I take that home with you
okay what's going on with you what's
your name so sha sha w okay right into
the mic the whole time yep there we go
all right you said instead of mine here
we go yeah yeah but oh I show you know
what I like who are you here with my
wife this beautiful woman I'm so glad
you dressed up with flip-flops look at
her she's a [ __ ] ten come on I got
some new sneakers she said and I said I
got some flip-flops and she said well
you should wear your new sneakers and I
said where you wearing flip-flops to
okay can you stand up here for me can
you come on up here come on just for a
second please come on up here please
come on please please please man please
please please please please please come
on now listen Shaw you have and I say
this very you've out kicked your
coverage yeah man let me tell you
something right now those roofies are
working but those what she's wearing are
not flip-flops bro okay can you hold
your feet up for a second those aren't
flip-flops I'm sayin so
you heard what her fate her feet are
showing yeah oh boy okay
okay so I'm not sure we have enough time
to explain it all so I but she bad thank
you so much for coming up here I
appreciate everybody thank you all right
man so this is man you know what I like
about you already you got you got a good
sense of humor
thank you you're on board okay give me
on a scale of one to ten how do you rate
yourself as a dancer she came out strong
with a nine but I'll tell you something
you better be at nine these people will
be disappears how you can tell he wasn't
confident because he would like this all
right yeah yeah yeah do that
yeah without a V in that seven do it
again yeah tell me how many bodies you
got bury in the backyard yeah
elem yeah no no no no dude dude this is
listenmi listenmi right now you're
already a crowd favorite it almost
doesn't matter what happens after this
if someone's gonna describe your dance
style in one word what would it be
Park a ladder well say that one word
again for me parka lighter percolator
[Applause]
[Music]
now let me tell you something let me
tell you something let me chase them I
have had there's only one other time
that where I've been so excited to watch
them on dance this dude came on stage
and he was brewing out hard he came up
hey what's your name he goes Kevin and I
go huh give me your number or you dance
Kevin what's your number of dance you
know seven and I go well give me your
one word to describe your dance style
and he grabs the mic with both Anthony
O's aggressive and I was like all [ __ ]
yeah I can't wait to see this dude yo
that does just a good yeah it sounds
good yes sounds [ __ ] great when you
said okay so I'm gonna let you go double
percolator all right so you or do you
want to give me the name of your death
dance move and said okay doubles listen
so sure is a soon no you got to do it
for them thank you and not only is his
dance style the percolator man that's
also the name of his best dance move I
know all of you are just trying to
picture in your head what the [ __ ] does
he mean
oh I can't wait man are you gonna flip
flops on or off oh when you're
percolating they might come off all
their [ __ ] weight thank you what's
your name step right up here
Oh Lainey Lainey Lainey thank you very
much for coming up here Lainey I
appreciate it calc right into the knot
[ __ ] into the mic talk right up so sorry
I'm [ __ ] a little high by the way
step right up it's gonna be fine we're
gonna have a good time they're gonna be
fun no no no no but guess what I want to
tell you guys something right now well
you three have so much respect for me I
come on the stage every night I still
get kind of nervous the balls it took
for you three to come up here you have
my complete respect 100% and let me tell
you something if you think your
possibility you're gonna embarrass
yourself Julie I think he's gonna make
up for it
I love this guy
see and I mean we're good so tell me one
through ten how do you rate yourself as
a Dan seven Wow all right sounded a lot
like you're about to say aggressive 0.7
I like your style lady I like your style
one word to describe your dance style
sloppy
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] really funny oh now I
don't know which I don't know because do
I want to see an actual good dancer
which is always great and hips I'm not
gonna lie to you make me tingle in my
nono spot
[Music]
maybe I'll see you later but I mean then
percolator
I thought her I thought there was no
coming back from percolator by Michael I
did sloppy
is funny as [ __ ] that is next-level
sloppy
I can't me too but you're gonna be
percolating so don't you write the name
of your best dance move I want you to
make it up okay sloppy joe I got the
munchies and they will sound [ __ ]
delicious right now
I'll take all I can get yeah I've said
that before okay can I have that
everyone's gonna dance the same verse
Jen you are definitely going first
I'm so happy you're up here I'm not
kidding here we go just the first verse
that's a whole be careful I've heard
that before too
[Applause]
okay you are
my fire the one yeah geez I believe when
I say
I won't either
everybody
sure here up man
Europe get in there Oh flip-flops off
everybody [ __ ] is about to go down
oh he's stretching hold on one second I
wanna I don't want him to pull anything
while he's percolating did it yeah I
know it's real prick
why were you planning on doing something
against the wall percolating yeah I'm
gonna percolate all over that wall I'll
tell you something nobody's expecting
you to dance in rhythm so dance as fast
as you want
it doesn't matter get down man go in
triple time you got it you almost can't
[ __ ] this up the only way you could [ __ ]
this up is if you turned into like a
really good dancer people would be like
well [ __ ] we had one of those already ah
here we go he's turning the whale hat
around do you have any idea what he's
gonna do do you oh she just went like
this to you that must have hurt okay
here we go you are
[Music]
you are my fire
Jesus
when I say I won't either
that's good man that's good you got it
now
listen listen yeah hi I'm so glad you
didn't leave here with a concussion
alright wait a second
the one thing I should have pointed out
ahead of time hey don't blow your wad in
the first round I should have told you
that okay here we go yeah okay here we
go
no you got one more yeah one more woman
Laney get up here yes you can your
standard is sloppy you can hit it
[ __ ] here we go
because she's like you know what if
sloppy doesn't work
these might I don't disagree here we go
you uh wait a second where the [ __ ] did
he go okay
[Music]
and desire believe when I say
[Applause]
he that
all right everybody come to the middle
over here on my right start with will
who might as well start with Shaw hi
first show everybody Lanie
Jen
[Music]
ooh that is tough Jen thank you so much
for coming up here
you are
my fire
geez I
[Music]
say
I won't either
ever we ha ha
I can't do you soon
when
I won't eat that way and tell me why why
ain't nothin but a heart
tell me why mistake tell me why I only
wanna PC
only that
see everybody
is too
the distance I want you to know that
deep down inside me
[Music]
you
[Music]
this
there are you know everybody Wow well
alright you can separate from each other
did you pull a hammy yeah okay alright
that's what you get when you percolate
you know what I mean sometimes you
sometimes you percolate a little too
hard and [ __ ] people get hurt you know
it's a little stiff yeah
don't whisper that in my ear okay here
we go he just whisk up to me he was like
it's a little stiff I'm like I got a man
yeah yeah no no you didn't say yeah okay
that's not bad guys this is a tough
choice for you
it sounded intense Laney
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey just Wilson okay yeah man you ready
I mean listen I just want you to know
what is happening right now are you
having a stroke
is the [ __ ] weirdest thing I've ever
seen buddy Sean one time
[Applause]
you know you know what's about to happen
we're gonna get fifty two both servers
go great job great job great job you
guys are a hell of a [ __ ] crap
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]